thank you guys so much for coming as you
can see I'm with my very special friend
someone I respect I admire I'm an Uber
fan of shark T it's Damon John everybody
thank you thank you for having me as
always well this is my favorite show to
come with I love it oh that means so
much to me and um this is actually a
very special show because this is about
something that you do in your life and
we're here to honor that today will you
tell us about Black entrepreneur day
yeah so it is called black entrepreneurs
day this is my fourth year I started
this in uh 2020 as a way to celebrate
thank you uh celebrate giving back and
supporting the black community and black
businesses and uh now we've given up to
around 700,000 uh to date and we're
giving more so JP Morgan and Chase is
with me you're supporting me right here
the audience is supporting me and that's
it yeah can I ask you a question yeah
when you were trying to start your first
business getting a bank loan didn't come
easy it didn't come I got to turn down
my 28 Banks yeah yeah and then your mom
uhhuh did something to help you raise
the money my mother took out her
mortgage on her home right and she got a
$100,000 Equity Mortgage now the house
was worth 75 till today I haven't asked
her what she did for the rest of the
money shout out to moms shout out to
moms to get it done and uh most critical
uh thing to learn from that is I almost
blew the $100,000 not knowing how
business works and I was about to risk
every single thing my mother ever had
worked for we were about to be homeless
and that's why we do things like black
entrepreneurs to show you if you have
money or what you should do because
having money is not a challenge normally
it's how to use it it's a tool and
that's that's what I really want people
to understand and is that the money that
you started FUBU with I started well I
started FUBU with $40 I mean yeah that's
a huge
jugut
amazing you know iconic
brand this is so inspiring because it's
hopeful it and we're going to get
takeaways today and um to kick it off
we're about to meet this like absolute
CutiePie I can't even stand it he's 13
years old he's an entrepreneur who
turned his mom's love of candles um
apparently I let him tell it but he's
actually a huge fan of you and uh we
want to surprise him because he has no
idea you're here right now so let's do
this please welcome Alejandro
buckon meet
you what are you doing here oh you know
I came to hang out I heard you going to
be
her remind me of a younger version let's
turn around you look just like a little
younger version of
[Applause]
me nice to meet
you can you tell everyone why you
started a smell of Love candles yeah so
I started smell Love candles when my mom
really loved candles like trust me she
loved her candles but our candles know
that she burned we giving her headaches
um you know I have asthma so triggered
so she was disappointed that her candles
were doing this so she threw all away so
she was really sad so you know I wanted
you know I don't like see my mom
disappointed so I want to create a
candle for her so it just really
inspired me to create this business can
I ask you like why do you think you're
so motivated I'm just motivated by the
love that she gives me and I'm and she
motivates me
yeah oh God that'll do it I can't wait
to show my kids this
episode it's just so inspiring on behalf
of all moms thank you for being you
thank you thank you for having me on the
show and then didn't know you were going
to be here I was inspired by my mother
as well you know um when my father left
and life had happened I watched my
mother work three jobs with the same
amount of food on table she worked once
so I started my first business cuz I
didn't want to see my mother work that
hard your mom Patricia is right here
hi with all due respect I need to ask
you a mom advice question how are you
raising such a incredible
son I don't have words you know I nobody
sets out to become a single parent and I
think you know our family is very small
so he set out to build this extended
family for us and pretty much everybody
who encourages him I mean it just
motivates him and it fuels that fire so
just from Mom to Mom wow like
seriously all right let's sit down every
everybody all right um all right here
take a seat you come sit in the middle
um all right um can I ask you obviously
you have the man right here would you
like to ask any questions um ad I would
ask for advice so how do we get to the
other point where we're in stores and we
have warehouse space where do we find
that bridge well um so how many candles
have you sold yeah so by the end of 2022
we sold more than 16,000 candles which
is so
candles and how did you sell them um not
in stores online yes we do online and we
do like markets all over the DMV so um I
would suggest not going into stores you
see if you make it for five you sell it
to the store at 10 and they sell it for
20 but if you're selling direct you make
it for five you sell it directly for 20
uh if the store sells it you don't know
who bought it all right but if you sell
it direct you know who bought it right
so there's only three ways to deal with
a customer you find a new one
you upsell a current one or you make one
buy more frequently right you want to
Super siize everybody's fries right uh
and the way to do that is having this
communication of growing a community
like you're doing already I would say
stay away from stores at the moment okay
and keep shipping directly and that's
the best way to succeed and this is such
a new world because we never had Direct
to Consumer we never had internet
marketing we never had social media um
and actually there's someone in social
media that I am obsessed with and his
name is Sir candleman he's been in the
fragrance industry he has over 300,000
social media followers and he is going
to take you on to have a meeting and see
what he can do with you that's
[Applause]
great wow that amazing um so it's not
only that um tret is a company that's
also providing HR Solutions for four
small businesses and we all need those
and today they want to give you a check
for
$110,000
Wow Wow there you go amazing thank you I
have
words okay well thank you Alejandro um
okay we also have another entrepreneur
who backstage and we have a surprise for
them after the break so stick around
we'll be right
[Music]
back